st. Louis Missouri for John and Joy's
insane flame gamer oh do not try this at
home how do you take a classic game like
Jenga to the next level first you make
it eight times bigger and then you set
it on fire how are they not burning
their hands
good question hotshot scientists over to
you this is all thanks to an amazing gel
this gel is a special fire retardant
made from a super absorbent cross-linked
polymer this is an inter linking network
of long-chain molecules with side chains
that are sticking out when this material
is exposed to water the small side
chains become negatively charged this
means that they repel each other and
unfurl to create a much larger Network
the negative side chains also attract
the hydrogen in water molecules which is
slightly positive this means that loads
of water is trapped inside the polymer
network structure once the polymer is
soaked up several hundred times its own
weight in water it forms a jail that we
see covering John and Joey's hands
Volta has a very high specific heat
capacity which means it takes a lot of
energy to evaporate it from a liquid
into a gas and this means it's a really
good choice for protecting their hands
John Joey you're the first guys to nail
flaming Jenga and we hope you're the
last I think you should go without
saying but i'ma say it don't try this at
home